republicans aren't even involved in the
culture war what was it jesse kelly i
think said
republicans law democrats won the
culture war because they were the only
ones fighting it
so this is this is um you know i know
i'm not supposed to do this but this is
uh william
buckley you know this is the problem
with his famous phrase so
his famous phrase was uh a conservative
is someone who stands a
thwart history yelling stop right
well if you're just someone who's
standing at thwart history yelling stop
and yet other people are going to say
hey let's try this let's go here was he
insulting conservatives
no that was his that i mean that is like
his i'm this is like his most
famous yeah quote that's attributed to
him who wouldn't want to be a
conservative
right you know and it's he's not
actually now
if you are a conservative you can say
well oh i see what he's saying we need
to preserve institutions that
and social norms and and culture and
morality that have
sustained us for all these years etc etc
but
if that's your tactic to just sit there
and say stop
we're not going to do any of this
anymore it's like
no one's going to come to your party no
but nobody's going to show up
he's right you're not offering anyone
anything that he has right that's
exactly what conservatives and and
always follow no he but he's identified
the group
they didn't adhere to what he said he
identified a group of people
that just said uh we're good here and
that's it
they're not fighting so i don't know but
standing so you could just stand there
and say stop do you know
ryan with this little bow tie i think
there's a lot of things in this country
that need to change but i think there's
a lot of things that that are good we
want to keep the good
you it's it's imagi imagine you know
what these these communists are
the the overstate these the party
members they represent a group that says
we got this amazing skyscraper let's
tear the whole thing down and then live
amongst the rubble as we rebuild
then you have conservatives who are like
the building's fine as it is stop
and then you've got other people who are
saying we can probably improve this
building quite a bit
let's keep it and get rid of the broken
parts and put in goodbyes i like those
people that's that's that's what i have
that makes the most sense so yeah i
don't identify with those who are like
this
this is my problem with with um the way
that a lot of people have been going
against the crt debate the critical race
theory debate
which and don't get me wrong i think
people are doing fantastic work chris
ruppo uh specifically on on that front
but
if you're just going to be one of these
governors who says i'm banning critical
race theory and critical race theory bad
like okay but
if you ever come out of power they can
just take that away right
you need to be explaining to people
the alternative you need to be
explaining to people
what is number one true history but then
also
why right why are these things
considered good
and this is considered bad you can't
just say to people oh we're going to ban
this and this this is out
then i think that's why i think
conservative is probably the wrong word
some populist maybe is a better word for
it you know when we had charlie kirk on
the show he mentioned that during occupy
the conservative movement wasn't ready
for a lot of these things
like calling out the corporations and
censorship and wall street and big tech
and things like that
and i'm like i don't think conservatives
ever are because they're literally
always just saying stop
reactionary so what those reactionaries
are uh yeah reactionaries oppose the
revolution
right so reactionary is a term that came
up during the french revolution and so
it was actually
a propaganda term used by the the
jacobins
and the the murderous authoritarians of
the french revolution
who to for their political opponents who
said hey maybe we
shouldn't kill everybody and destroy all
of french culture you know maybe we can
just start go around
executing people because we decided we
want to um they were
they were called reactionary so this was
actually a propaganda term
used by the red terror right right right
so
uh for back to the conservative
statement the populist is maybe a better
word
the libertarians are very much involved
but they don't like donald trump i think
with like uh
dave smith and the mises caucus you
actually have strong principled
libertarians now who
very much so will say they don't like
donald trump but very much so we'll
oppose a lot of what the democrats are
doing
and i think that's something a lot of
the populists actually agree with so
they might not agree
with criticism of trump but i think the
one thing that trump animated
or the one thing about trump that
animated a lot of people was
anti-establishment
i think there's substantially more
anti-establishment people
in whatever this faction is so i don't
know what the right word is to describe
them
the people who are actually demanding
things you look at people like you know
lauren bobert or mary taylor green
who actually say hey we want a thing
most republicans are like we're gonna
we say no to democrats i'm like well
what are you for what are you actually
advocating for
okay i'm smiling right now because you
you mentioned those and
i want everyone to know that i didn't
say anything to tim
prior to this show you mentioned those
two names
just because you see these two people
who are fighting right you look in the
news and they're actively fighting four
things
when i said that there were potentially
members of congress
that were on the joe biden list
it was exactly those two marjorie taylor
green and laura
i i just just those two like here's our
list it's two
so far i mean again i don't know if this
is the final list but
there's the two members of congress that
i was told you know what they've done
you know you know what big tech has done
by banning
people on the right they have made sure
that the only voices you hear
are the for the most part spineless
weak republicans who just say please
stop democrats
the fierce fighting angry people who are
like this is what we want and why we
want it all have been banned
not all but mostly so now what they've
done is well they're banned or atomized
what do you mean what do you mean by
atomizer so atomize is a great example
for
uh you know margery taylor green right
yes it's like right you know you we've
we've isolated you we've broken you down
to your constituent atoms we're you're
you're not a republican right and they
force her to go through these struggle
sessions
and even the republicans right and
that's what i say like even mccarthy
is kind of saying well i'm going to
strip her over committees but i'm not
going to kick her out of the caucus and
all that like so he's going along with
it
they want to control he goes along with
this so this is this atomization of
er it's and it's it's part of an other
rising um this goes back to
you know it actually goes back to uh
what the german stasi would do
in in east germany because when they
realized that it got to a certain point
where they were disappearing too many
people and
they realized that okay you know this is
getting a little bit too untenuous for
us
well okay what we're gonna do then is
instead of of
you know disappearing you and locking
you up because that's hard it costs
money right you need to go through trial
etc
we're just going to destroy your
reputation right we're just going to
destroy what people think of you we're
going to smear you
we're going to attack you we're going to
use all of our power implements
so that people yeah you can be out there
and you can have your quote unquote free
speech
but no one will listen to you yeah they
they
amazingly condemn marjory taylor green
for things she said before she was even
in office
right kevin mccarthy goes along with
everything the democrats say and it's
very obvious the established republicans
and the democrats are part of the
uniparty and right now the republicans
are just
frantic because there is an invasive
force of populists who have
come in and started making changes so
maybe
what will happen is uh they'll put that
they'll put out that list oh lauren
beaubert and marjorie taylor green are
on that list huh
i'd imagine the america first candidates
the right-wing populist candidates
obviously huge overlap the ones who are
trying to primary they're all going to
be labeled extremists
there's going to be stories in every
major newspaper about oh these
republicans they're they're evil and
dangerous we can't let them win and by
the way
i don't know if anyone saw this but this
is this is a huge
problem that the populists have right
liz cheney right liz chaney who is sort
of the
the avatar of sort of the anti-populace
she's the avatar of the establishment
winger she's
been propped up as this she just raised
1.8 million
right she actually put up the highest
numbers for any house member
right that's liz cheney now i'd like to
go through that 1.8 million yeah
exactly where's all that coming from
well the squad members raised most of
their money outside their districts
squadrons caliber
money this is going to come down
to a money fight and there are extremely
powerful
interests that are fighting against this
and so i i do believe by the way that
populists have the upper hand in terms
of numbers right now i do
i really do but the money side is going
to get filtered in
they've broken the working class oh sure
you might have the working class on your
side
a million grassroots donors who are too
broke now because the economy's been
destroyed
to actually give you a penny to help
your campaign yeah when uh the roman
empire fell apart completely the the
middle class eviscerated and evaporated
it was gone
they completely disseminated the you
working you've got
these elites worth the the the net worth
of the billionaires went up
substantially
the major corporations stock values
started to skyrocket
small businesses destroyed and what did
that help do
destroy grassroots activism
bernie sanders famously had an average
donation of 23
or whatever that night and once again
asking but he was but bernie was able to
to rise up because he had the people on
his side
and all of that money flowing into him
empowered him greatly well
be it fortuitous for the establishment
that they have destroyed the economy and
hurt the working class and made them
mostly destitute and homeless
and living off of government welfare and
unemployment bills and child tax credits
now
you could have 10 million supporters if
they're too broke to donate to you
they don't but the wealthy elites whose
net worth went up we were they could
donate whatever they want to whoever
they want super pacs
so we went to the um you know i
mentioned you mentioned the workers
right
we were out in nevada for the ufc fight
um
we went to joe rogan and dave chappelle
the night before and then because we're
rogan's in town because he does
commentary so we go to mcgregor and
poirier
and at the stadiums where we're going at
the arenas where we were going to show
up
they the concession stand the line
was like 40 minutes long for each of
them why
you would go up and you see there's only
two people working behind the stand
there wow
wow that's it right because that town
that city was which is that's that's the
entertainment capital of of the state
right that's that's their entire economy
it was decimated by kovid and then now
they have a worker shortage because
there's so many people
that are living off government and say
hey i get this money for free
for that i got to go deal with drunk
people i got to go deal with you know
whatever you got my order wrong so i got
to go deal with emotional abuse why go
back to work if i'm if i can still get
down for money for this it's a massive
worker shortage out there it's a time
bomb you know
it's uh the bill will come do
they're the it's it's which law of
thermodynamics uh ian
you know perhaps the second law of
thermodynamics second law to be honest i
don't know
are you talking about uh when an object
in motion will remain in motion
forced upon uh this idea that you can
get things for free without making
things
oh free energy yeah eventually what
happens is there
the value of the dollar becomes zero
because
why work well the problem with the
thermodynamic thing that says you can't
get more energy out of a system than you
put into it
only assumes that there's a closed
system that you're working with them but
in reality there are no closed
systems energy can always come from
further away than we knew it existed so
i do believe zero opponents mean like
slave labor in china yeah like there
will always be more slaves we can always
have more children to make them more
slaves that i've kind of been
joking around but i'm like americans
spending money and not producing
anything won't last
we'll have to default on it that we're
going to have to default on the phone
and by the way this this
this all goes back to the 90s this goes
back to nafta
this goes back to china and wt goes back
to 79.
this goes back it goes back and back
this was the idea
china will be the manufacturing base
right that will be china that will be
moved to china right and then america
will be
the consumers america will say you sit
there
you're going to you know whatever is the
new movie that gets rolled off the
island line you're all going to go watch
it
then and now they don't even need to do
that now you're just streaming right you
can just sit in your home
and you're going to have it delivered to
you and you click this and you say oh
i'm going to watch this
and then and then you just go on to the
next one and you go on to the next one
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time